12h13 face à la première
[Musique]
voici soixante ans une grève des
ouvriers agricoles du secteur de la
canne prend une tournure tragique au
lamentin le vendredi 24 mars 1961 à la
sortie de la messe une fusillade
déclenchée par des gendarmes provoque la
mort de trois jeunes
le retentissement de ce nouvel épisode
de répression sociale est considérable
le maire communiste georges gracia est
démis de son mandat après avoir prononcé
un hommage émouvant aux victimes six
décennies après événement est commémorée
par la ville au travers d'une série de
conférences ayant pour support la
projection d'un film documentaire
intitulé la turbie 24 mars 1961 une
tranche d'histoire du lamentin un film
réalisé en 2008 temps des collégiens je
vous souhaite la bienvenue dans face à
la première ce dimanche 21 ans 2021 à
l'ecoute de l'émission politique
hebdomadaire de la rédaction de
martinique la première pour évoquer
cette séquence je vous présente nos
invités à cette émission réalisée par
jean louis bongo et édiles qui auriez
tout d'abord lors à l'honnêteté bonjour
madame l'honnêté longchamp êtes l'une
des protagonistes de ce film nous allons
en discuter largement tout le long de
l'émission je signale que vous êtes la
réalisatrice de ce film documentaire
mais vous allez me donner des précisions
tout à l'heure et vous collaborerez au
service comme chez soi de l'office de la
culture du lamentin ou next floor est
tout à l'heure de quoi il s'agit avec
votre camarade de l'équipe de tournage
qui a été le cas devant le caméraman
comme on dit en français facile
anthony lanfry silence merci d'avoir
accepté notre invitation vont également
comme laura l'honnêté vous collaborez à
ce service de l'office de la culture du
lamentin qui a que vous encadrez
d'ailleurs à l'époque pour réaliser ce
film est en fait avec nous valériane
edmond-mariette bonjour madame n mon
oreillette
bonjour à toutes et à tous ainsi pour
votre disponibilité également c'est vous
qui avez animé certaines conférences
débats
un cadre de cette commémoration de ce
60e anniversaire de la tuerie de mars
1961 vous êtes doctorante en histoire à
l'université des antilles votre sujet de
thèse mémoire de l'esclavagé colonial
société et musique aux antilles
françaises de 1956 aller à kassav mais
ce n'est pas le sujet du jour
je rappelle que vous êtes fondatrice de
all i want l'histoire d'une plateforme
de diffusion de vulgarisation de
transmission de vos recherches et
notamment vous proposer des visites du
circuit coloniale la ville de fort de
france
des balades commentées mais dans
plusieurs autres communes tout à fait
tout à fait bien mais merci d'avoir
accepté notre invitation vous à tous les
trois trentenaires on va pas peut-être
vouloir dire votre âge précis si vous ne
souhaitez pas mais enfin ces produits
aujourd'hui je suis environné de jeunes
de la génération montante et donc pour
évoquer cet épisode méconnu aujourd'hui
on en parle comme ça on lors de
conférences débats il y à ce film
documentaire
effectivement cet événement tragique qui
a été l'assassinât de trois personnes
qui sortaient de la messe au centre
ville du lamentin le 24 mars 1961 et
avant de revenir sur les circonstances
de ce drame de parler du film
documentaire retraçant cet épisode
méconnu de notre histoire sociale et
politique
une question comment elle voit arriver
personnellement à vous intéresser à ce
moment là leur alone était alors à ce
moment là donc l'histoire déjà de la
réalisation de ce documentaire c'est
suite à un voyage pédagogique que nous
avons fait dans le service allô pour
vraiment bien comprendre les choses
le service comme chez soi anciennement
cellule est issu d'un projet urbain donc
et aux balles entre la martinique les
pays latins et c'était au temps du des
conseils communaux des villes donc mon a
été le premier ccjm du lamentin et on
avait comme projet en fait de de pouvoir
enfin un espace où les jeunes pouvaient
vraiment venir sont retrouvés participer
aux différentes animations de la ville
et enfin voilà en tout cas être au
niveau acteurs au niveau de la ville
avec des animations qu'ils auraient
choisi donc on a décidé de l'appeler
comme chez soi
voilà et qui était donc le chef de
projet mal la nouvelle retour qui avec
qui nous avons fait plusieurs voyages
pédagogiques donc nous sommes pas anti
étant jumelée avec santiago de cuba le
la montée nous sommes partis en 2006 5 7
7 mais aussi anthony à cuba et c'est
vrai que on a à la rencontre de ces
jeunes cubains donc qu'ils étaient de
notre âge mais aussi plus petits
c'est vrai qu'ils étaient vraiment très
très vif de demande sur notre histoire
l'histoire de la martinique histoire du
lamentin savoir si on avait des héros
nationaux
quel combat et lutte que nous avions eus
nous ont parlé d'aimé césaire enfin
voilà ils étaient vraiment intéressés et
nous on était un petit peu bloquée par
rapport à certaines réponses puisque il
faut dire les choses
en tant que jeune bull jeune adolescent
c'est vrai qu'on ne n'était pas vraiment
au fait de notre histoire ont beau
sonner on était là et c'est vrai qu'au
bout de la première
vos premières rencontres on a droit à
ces questions la deuxième rencontre bon
au bout de obou d'un certain moment on
s'est dit bon là à chaque fois on me
pose des questions sur notre notre notre
histoire notre commune on sait rien ça
devient frustrant surtout et on s'est
dit justement ça peut être ça peut être
un projet donc autour de ça et puis on
avait avec nous un administrateur
présent donc monsieur hollande elle qui
nous un petit peu aiguilles et là dessus
et de la partie le projet jeunes avocats
murat qui a donné la première
réalisation du service comme chez soi
donc j'étais au collège et anthony nasri
à ce moment là puisque leurs longs étés
disait que c'était dans le cadre du
conseil municipal des représentants de
la câble du oui une sorte de conseil
municipal des jeunes alors mettez en
conseil et après du projet le projet
et elle émerger en tant que cellule
comme chez soi pourquoi vous avez adhéré
à ce projet personnellement il faudra
voir que nous en tant que jeune on ma
dit un truc que j'ai normal mais en fait
nous on a intérêt à l'office de la
culture du lamentin
en tant que jeune adhérent à ce service
est en fait au lieu de traîner dans les
rues de ne rien faire mais en fait on
avait décidé de se rassembler tous les
mercredis et enseignement mercredi et
samedi
et en fait on partager nos idées on
essayait de mettre en place des projets
comme celui ci et ça a donné ce
documentaire il pas que alors justement
parlons en solo mais pourquoi vouloir
mettre en lumière un épisode quand même
assez singulier qui certes beaucoup de
la matinée s'en souviennent encore parce
qu'ils ont vécu ou alors ce sont les
enfants de deux témoins ou des personnes
qui ont vécu ces événements dramatiques
mais il ya plein d'autres choses que
vous auriez pu montrer en tant que jeune
pourquoi c'est sur cet épisode
particulier alors pourquoi précisément
cette cet événement parce que des
premiers homo on va dire où nous sommes
basés donc le service comme chez soi
c'est au centre culturel du bourg du
lamentin et donc c'est une ancienne
cantine en fait et c'est vraiment au
coeur de ces vraiment là qui a eu les
manifestations et qui a eu qui a eu
l'événement sachant que la rue qui est
juste dans la médiathèque qui est
adjacente à la médiathèque s'appelle
24.61 donc on était vraiment au coeur
aussi on peut dire de l'action alors
qu'est ce que vous a plu de ce projet
vous au torino et qu'est ce qui nous a
plu ben alors personnellement pas oui
qu'est ce que je vous dis vous aurez pu
parler de sport faire autre chose mais
l'histoire sociale et politique
quand on a quand et à quel âge
aviez-vous peur à l'époque j'étais au
collège donc au collège en écho aux
mineurs je pense que
alors à mes souvenirs j'avais peut-être
13 14 ans alors voilà donc jeunes de
13-14 ans s'intéresse à un épisode
sanglant à une grève d ouvrir l'école ce
n'est pas banal
c'est vrai que de soi-même on va pas s'y
intéresser
mais vu que nous sommes dans deux dans
une équipe en concertation donc du coup
on a voulu le faire et apprendre à le
faire
donc du coup c'est vrai que ce serait
pas la première
on pense pouvoir faire quelque chose
mais à partir de ce moment là on a pris
goût à le faire donc du coup on a fait
des recherches
c'est facile pas de la science fiction
bien des loisirs et ensuite on se dit ah
oui c'est quand même passé des choses et
on s'est posé la question aussi est-ce
qu'il n'y avait pas nos parents de donne
aux anciens remparts aussi nom de la
famille donc du coup de fil en aiguille
des recherches énoncé diabète c'était
juste à côté
donc qu'est ce qu'il y avait avant
puisque tout ne se situe pas la même
chose aujourd'hui mais au fur et à
mesure ça a été en a pris goût je
m'entraîne vers historienne valériane
edmond-mariette vous vous prononcer des
conférences pour certaines puisqu'il ya
une vingtaine d'événements depuis un an
de moins depuis le 21 janvier jusqu'au 3
mars dans les écoles et dans plusieurs
cars entiers de la montagne au quotidien
pour le public adulte re- pour le public
très scolaire pourquoi avez-vous adhéré
à cette idée de venir accompagner ces
jeunes pour parler de cet événement
eh bien d'abord parce que j'ai qui sont
venus me chercher c'est pas c'est comme
ça que les choses se sont passées ils
ont ils sont venus me chercher l'office
de la culture est venu me chercher c'est
vrai que aux dépenses qui a été la
motivation c'est mon concept de balade
historique avec cette idée qu'au cours
de la balade finalement on se pose des
questions et on parle de l'histoire de
manière décomplexée et quelque peu
banale si je puis dire les choses ainsi
entre guillemets mais rapidement il ya
eu adhésion que et notamment dans les
quartiers
il y a une explication qui soit jointe
au visionnage du documentaire si le
documentaire en lui-même
même pour un documentaire de jeunes
collégiens qui datent de 13 ans qui
n'ont aucune maîtrise de l'audiovisuel
etc qui découvre les choses et où on a
quand même un documentaire qui est qui
correct qui est qui est vraiment correct
l'idée c'est de pouvoir répondre aux
questions qui que qui vont surgir après
le visionnage mais aussi d'apporter des
pistes de réflexion et des éléments de
compréhension du contexte parce que
finalement si dans ce documentaire au
cours de ces 26 minutes on a quand même
un contexte qui est bien dégrossi dans
le détail il ya des choses que les gens
n'arrivent pas à appréhender donc je
suis là pour ça et essayer de le faire
de la manière la plus simple et la plus
abordable possible
alors avant de revenir dans le détail du
contenu documentaire vu de ses
réalisations
quelques éléments de contexte de cette
fusillade mortelle qui a eu lieu je le
rappelle au lamentin le 24 mars 1961 le
contexte relativement simple et
classique qu'il s'agit d'une grève des
ouvriers du secteur de la canne trois
victimes seront relevés parmi la foule
qui fuyait les balles des gendarmes
rappellent signé fabrice théodose
vendredi 24 mars 1961 centre ville du
lamentin la messe de karen se termine
les fidèles s'apprête à rentrer chez eux
soudain des coups de feu des gendarmes
mobiles postés près de l'église tirs à
balles réelles sur la foule surprise
bousculade panique
bilan trois morts tués par balle dans le
dos susan mary calixte 24 ans couturière
marcellin laurence in vain
vendredi 24 mars 1961 centre ville du
lamentin la messe de karen se termine
les fidèles s'apprêtaient à rentrer chez
eux
soudain des coups de feu des gendarmes
mobiles postés près de l'église tirs à
balles réelles sur la foule surprise
bousculade panique
bilan trois morts tués par balle dans le
dos susan mary calixte 24 ans couturière
marcellin laurence in 21 ans ouvrier
agricole edouard valide 26 ans ouvrier à
picot lui aussi ce sont les trois
victimes de cet épisode répressif ce
vendredi sanglant est le point culminant
d'une énième grève des ouvriers de la
canne
le motif est récurrent l'augmentation
des salaires
et ce n'est pas la dernière après celle
du françois en 1900 du carbet en 1948 de
la chasse un as du cos en 1951
sans oublier la marche de la faim en
1935 le maire du lamentin georges gracia
avocats ténors du barreau dirigeants du
parti communiste prononce une oraison
funèbre en ce jour des obsèques des
trois victimes et ses propos sont clairs
qui veut du pain aura du plomb au nom de
la loi au nom de la force au nom de la
france au nom de la force de la loi qui
vient de la france
son discours se trois tombes du vaut
d'être poursuivi par le ministre des
armées pierre messmer il sera suspendu
puis après réintégré dans ses fonctions
de maire la tuerie du 24 mars 1961
méconnu laissera des traces profondes au
sein de la population la monty noise
elle aura révélé une fois de plus la
précarité de la vie des ouvriers
agricoles
voilà rappeur appelé de manière très
résumé le contexte de l'époque l'oral on
était quelque chose à ajouter si on sent
quelques précisions
si je veux me permettre alors il a parlé
de 6 anne marie calixte mais c'est
annette amicalistes en fait parce que au
cours de nos investigations de jeunes à
la réalisation on s'est rendu compte
qu'il y avait un problème sur la plaque
commémorative parce qu'il y avait déjà
une plaque commémorative au niveau 2 en
face de la médiathèque au lamentin mais
en fait il ya eu un problème pour les
prénoms voilà d'accord et sur le
circonstances historiques vous avez
travaillé sur quels documents sur
quelles archives toning alors dans un
premier temps on a recherché dans les
archives de la ville du lamentin
ensuite on a été voir dans les familles
éventuellement s'il y avait des
personnes qui étaient au courant de
cette histoire est aussi nous avons été
aux archives départementales et aussi on
a ici devant un petit peu sur certaines
connaissances que nous avions d'un site
sur lequel est que nous pu être relaté
ces faits et puis voilà c'est comme ça
qu'on a travaillé et puis de fil en
aiguille on a connu des personnes par
d'autres personnes et qui a donné alors
je disais tout à l'heure que cette grève
est relativement classique parce que
habituel au début de la récolte de la
canne depuis janvier février mars et
souvent au moment où on a des conflits
pas tout le temps mais très souvent pas
les organes edmond mariette
en fait cette grève s'inscrit dans une
longue tradition de luttes sociales des
ouvriers de la canne pour améliorer
leurs vies et leurs conditions de
travail et simplement
oui voilà en fait on est dans un
contexte de crise sucrière le crise le
sucre pardon le sucre de canne
finalement est moins utilisé en france
donc il n'y a plus besoin d'avoir cet
apport massif et donc on a toutes une
toute une économie en fait qui est en
train de s'effondrer mais au-delà de ça
le l'économie sucrière à toute une toute
une toute autre symbolique pour la
société martiniquaise de l'époque
l'économie sucrière c'est la survivance
de l'institution ni aux esclavagistes
qui est l'habitation puisqu'en fait
quand on regarde entre 1848 et par
exemple 1961 qui nous intéresse la
l'habitation et le fonctionnement et les
rapports sociaux sur l'habitation n'ont
pas changé en fait si on a eu la baule
ition et qu'on a le droit de vote qu'on
y citoyens qu'entre temps la martinique
est devenue département français
d'outre-mer en 1961
on est dans un contexte où l'habitation
et notamment dans le secteur de la canne
à sucre qui est prépondérant et même
s'il s'effondre à ce moment là on est
dans dans dans les rôles en dans les
héritages de la société esclavagiste et
donc à la fois c'est une revalorisation
qu'il demande mais aussi une meilleure
considération finalement
de leurs conditions de travail une
amélioration de ses conditions une
revalorisation de leur personne et la
possibilité de mourir dignement leurs
enfants en fait donc c'est vrai que il y
à autant de grèves et cette espèce de
2,2 phase éruptive qui est assez
régulier en finalement quand on regarde
beaucoup comme comme comme il a été dit
dans l'extrait que nous avons entendu la
1900 chassaing 1948 etc ces espèces de
cette espèce de récurrence et parce
qu'en fait il n'y a pas la fin de ses
mécanismes de domination et qu' il faut
sortir de cela en fait chaque année il y
à une remise en cause des acquis des
ouvriers chaque année il faut revenir à
la lutte pour obtenir exactement minimum
vital
chaque année il ya une renégociation des
salaires je sais pas si vous vous
imaginez venir chaque année à martinique
1ère et être ne pas savoir combien vous
serez payés et être sous payés donc
c'est concrètement c'est littéralement
littéralement ce qui se passe alors pour
en revenir au film l'histoire de ce film
morano n'était alors vous à vous avais
dit le mot site faisait partie d'un
groupe de jeunes qui a monté ce projet
par consensus qui a proposé dont s'était
glissée à de cette séquence vous avez je
suppose on comptera sans doute de
difficultés et notamment quant au
témoignage est ce qu'il a été facile de
rock et des témoignages parce qu'en 1900
en 2008 quand le film a été réalisé je
rappelle ça fait comme le moment même si
les présenter au public encore un peu
partout aujourd'hui on l'a monté en tout
cas il y avait encore beaucoup de
personnes qui ont vécu de près ou
directement ces événements alors tout à
faire cesser les aléas de tournage et
encore plus madonna l'avait un peu
caustique ficultés quand on fait un
documentaire avec des interviews de
témoins c'est que en caméra ou parce
qu'on a on a déjà on a fait un premier
travail de deux rencontres donc avec une
fois comme anthony a dit après avoir
accueilli mais les numéros d'untel ou
d'untel etc
et une fois que
qu'il fallait passer devant la caméra
c'est surtout passer devant la caméra
qui fait beaucoup plus peur aux gens en
fait et on s'est aussi rendu compte que
c'était encore un événement sensible
sensible dans la mémoire parce que c'est
vrai que du haut de nous de notre
adolescence on ne réalisait pas encore
la portée de l'événement lui même mais
c'est vrai que si on a vraiment été
entier à lille certains refus de d'être
filmé en tout cas voilà maintenant que
oui c'est un peu ça que allez vous
demander quels ont été vos principaux
obstacles parce que c'est vrai
recueillons des archives sur papier
c'est une chose recueillant des
témoignages des archives orales c'est
autre chose mais de là à les transformer
un sujet de film c'est encore un
troisième problème
oui enfin problème c'est à dire que à
partir du moment où on trouve que la
personne va va nous raconter ce qui
s'est passé en tout cas son vécu on va
prendre note
ça va nous sembler très intéressant et
bien le diable on va revenir pour
l'interviewer et en fait entre le jour
où on se rencontrait le jour du tournage
ce n'est pas l'or déjà qu'ils ont fait
de la caméra comme le dit laura mais le
discours n'est pas le même parfois ils
ont oublié des choses à savoir si c'est
volontaire ou pas mais c'est vrai que
haut niveau il y en a eu des difficultés
aussi au niveau des captations jusque il
fallait souvent reprennent par rapport à
la formulation qu'ils ont qu'ils ont
donnée aux défauts apparus n'oublie est
en fait tout ça c'est vrai que c'était
pas facile
bon après on a fait que les moyens du
bord donc c'est à certains moments
laisser tourner la caméra comme on le
connaît si bien et puis on a les prenait
un petit plus à gauche à doite ed rush
est dans une pièce montée
mais c'est vrai que c'était pas facile
alors vous vous hanter
vous étiez grande réussite a dit cameron
qu'est ce que vous a plu dans cette
fonction
alors il faut savoir que initialement
moi j'aime la photo donc du coup est ce
qu'au poste de la caméra j'ai aimé
j'aimais parce que je touchais un autre
secteur
c'était le secteur de la vidéo et
j'avais beaucoup à apprendre
peut-être pas forcément dans ces
conditions puisque il faut savoir que le
tournage était très intense a commencé
tôt ça se finit 7 ans il y avait aussi
des conditions météo et en fait des fois
on a envie de faire des choses même si
il y avait nathalie glouton qui nous
accompagnait ce sur la formation
audiovisuelle
mais des fois de soi même il ya des
choses qui se rêvait en haut vous voir
faire comme ça on a décidé de faire
comme ça et on lui dit ah ben non la
trame c'est comme ça il faut le faire
comme ça mais on a du mal à ce que
romain on a du mal à accepter ce qu'on
ai dit mais on n'a pas le choix il faut
entrer dans le canevas et c'est une
bonne expérience ou moins genre précise
que votre chef de projet celle qui
pilotait un peu tout s'est tu as fait un
manuel à noël étaient également assisté
par la formatrice en techniques
audiovisuelles nantais rigaudeau qui
d'ailleurs collaboratrice de martinique
la première aujourd'hui
valériane edmond-mariette il y as
souvent cette difficulté dans l'histoire
en tout cas l'histoire récente des
personnes qui ont vécu un événement 10
20 30 50 ans auparavant et c'est
toujours difficile de reconstituer ce
qui s'est passé parce que le souvenir
est là mais il ya également l'analyse
que l'on fait après le souvenir alors
quels pièges vous en tant qu'historienne
pensez vous qu'il faille éviter dans ce
genre de reconstitution historique face
à une caméra
moi je pense que d'abord il faut
vraiment avoir une connaissance pointue
du sujet c'est à dire que il ya une
phase dont anthony a parlé et qui est
extrêmement importante et que moi même
je fais un puisque je mène aussi des
enquêtes de terrain pour le coup c'est
vraiment enquête de terrain avec mon
magnétophone donc c'est pas filmer mais
c'est ben voilà 24 mois 61 consulter les
archives de la presse de l'époque
consulter finalement qu'est ce qui a été
dit aussi dans les rapports alors à ce
moment-là ils n'y ont pas eu accès
puisque on peut tout juste avoir accès à
ces rapports des forces de l'ordre
gendarmerie et police que moi j'ai pu
voir et que j'ai pu consulter
dans le cadre des commémorations
s'amender voilà récemment il ya des led
il ya un délai pour avoir accès à
certains documents et aujourd'hui nous
les chercheurs on peut y avoir accès
alors que pour l'instant le grand public
n'y a pas encore accès il faut attendre
encore quelques années il ya des lois
qui encadrent tout cela est donc pour le
coup ils n'avaient pas accès à cela mais
il faut bien connaître tout cela et
ensuite il faut aller vers le témoin
sans lui donner l'impression que sa
parole est toute puissante parce que sa
parole ne l'est pas maintenant sa parole
est légitime parce qu'il est témoin et
ces faits auxquels il a assisté qui pour
le coup sont défaits traumatique là il
n'y a pas de doute là dessus on a quand
même les forces de l'ordre la police et
les gendarmes qui ouvrent le feu sur une
foule où on compte à peu près 800 à 1000
personnes selon les rapports des forces
de l'ordre et donc on a ces personnes
qui sont fusillés mutilé parce qu'on
parle effectivement de ces trois
personnes qui sont assassinés mais à
côté de cela il y allait de lycée voilà
il donc on a ces personnes qui ont ce
vécu en sachant qu'on est dans un
contexte en 1961 au delà de la crise
sucrière à la martinique où il ya une
montée du communisme et il ya une
volonté de repenser le statut politique
de la martinique
la france elle est en pleine guerre
d'algérie en pleine guerre froide donc
communisme et velléités indépendantistes
ou autonomistes ça ne passe pas auprès
de la république du général de gaulle
donc il ya une volonté de répression qui
éclaire de l'état français à cette
période il n'y a pas de doute là dessus
et donc par rapport à cela
ces personnes que l'on aborde il faut
respecter leur parole
il ne s'agit pas de la mettre en doute
parce que on nous sommes quatre
personnes là si on raconte en sortant de
l'interview ce qu'on aura fait ce sera
chaud et on aura chacun notre vécu donc
il faut respecter cela
maintenant il faut toujours confronté en
tout cas quand on produit un travail
scientifique comme le mien il faut
toujours confronté tout cela est en fait
ne pas on a tendance à penser que
l'historien ou l'historienne est là pour
donner une vérité on est là pour
apporter des faits et permettre aux
personnes qui entendent parler de ces
faits aujourd'hui soixante ans après moi
je suis là pour donner des pistes aux
des réflexions des hypothèses et dans 60
ans j'espère que d'autres auront fait ce
travail et qu' ils diront d'autres
choses face à la première
jean mas parti
laurent launay t es ce que vous avez
souvenir du nombre de personnes que vous
avez rencontrées pour réaliser vos
recherches puis le film enfin voilà le
nom de personne c'est vrai qu'on a dû
voir rouge entre les appels
téléphoniques
allez vraiment sur le tir est vraiment
passé en caméra on a du web même pas
c'est vrai qu'on a eu on a eu beaucoup
d'appels téléphoniques mais en homme
concret jouit d'une bonne trentaine de
personnes de très large entre les
personnes qui avaient des photos des
personnes qui avaient des documents sur
le lamantin les témoins parce que alors
tout comme valeo yann disais et je
voulais le préciser on a voulu faire se
réaliser en tout cas ce documentaire de
façon de 3 donc c'est vraiment rapporter
des faits rapporté des faits on a
d'abord commencé par en parler du
contexte historique pour pouvoir bien
suite située la chose et après avoir les
témoins et puis surtout on remercie ceux
qui ont bien voulu déjà passé caméra
pouvoir laisser leur trace
tout ce qu'ils avaient a dit oui parce
que souvent les ont fait en tout cas si
je peux retenir quelque chose c'est que
toutes les personnes qu'on a rencontrés
avaient quand même quelque chose à dire
voilà il a ils ont cette soif de
transmettre puisqu'on a rencontré
principalement que des personnes d'âgés
et elles ont vraiment cette soif de
transmettre quelque chose là c'était des
événements mais en tout cas voilà je
reviens la toile historique à toile de
fond historique plutôt atone il inscrit
vous avez appris beaucoup de choses
évidemment
13 14 ans on est ouvert au monde en est
que oui on est comme une éponge là
qu'est ce qui vous a le plus si au prix
le plus indigne et le plus comme une
image
inité de tout ce que vous avez contre
angers comme informations sur cet
épisode alors me posais une question là
c'est bien simple question en fait c'est
c'est l'équipe de tournage en elle même
je ne pensais pas qu'il aurait fallu
autant de monde pour la réalisation de
fines en tout cas autant de cours de mix
aujourd'hui je perds pour ce langage à
l'époque non et voilà je ne pensais pas
qu'il y avait autant de métiers autour
du cinéma et pour réaliser le film
parce que pour moi c'était des gens
tuent à filmer alors il ya des caméras
intégrées
il y à des micros intégrés dans les
caméras ne savais pas qu'on pouvait
mettre un ingénieur du son pour capter
le son voilà et c'est ce qui m'a le plus
frappé aujourd'hui gens sont très riches
et j'en suis content et j'ai bien
toujours dedans aujourd'hui
alors quand même personne at-il fallu
pour réaliser le film justement alors
j'avais partie du tournage elle nous
étions une équipe de jeunes d'une
dizaine de jeunes de 15 à 20 jeunes en
plus laissés l'encadrement de son
encadrement donc nathalie claude ans
madame manuela retour et qu'il officiait
la culture et bill certains collègues de
l'office de la culture du lamentin alors
valérie anne marie est un jeu revient
également sur la toile de fond
historique la montée à l'époque est la
deuxième ville de martinique est très
industrielle et industrieuse il n'y a
pas encore les grandes zones
commerciales faussement après les zones
industrielles mon bref c'est autre chose
mais il n'ya pas encore toutes ses
infrastructures évidemment l'autoroute
n'est même pas à compenser la lettre
commence va commencer de l'être s'ils
ont encore une ville commerçante est une
ville agricole
est-ce que c'est parti est ce que cette
grève de mars nous sentir concernés
essentiellement ou uniquement la ville
du lamentin
alors cette grève touche tout le secteur
agricole de la canne à sucre 1 c'est
vrai que la grève débute le 28 février
1961 au lamentin où on a une
interruption du travail à l'usiné de
l'art ainsi il use in dessous d'eau qui
sont de très grosses usines puisqu'en
fait le lamantin des la colonisation
française va jouer ce rôle un peu de
grenier de lille
donc on va avoir cette vocation agricole
dès le départ je pense que la devise
aussi lamentin ville fertile n'est pas
complètement étrangère à cela
voilà c'est complètement lié tout cela
est en fait on a effectivement tous ces
ouvriers ces ouvrières qui vont se
mettre en grève progressivement ça va
gagner le sud le nord de lille françois
mas pointe on va avoir tout cela mais
c'est vrai que le lamantin joue un peu
le rôle de terreau parce qu'en fait de
lamentin comme vous disiez cette
deuxième ville en termes économiques
on a en 1961 environ 18000 habitants au
lamentin et sur ses dix-huit mille
habitants la majorité appartient au
secteur agricole
c'est des ouvriers et des ouvrières
agricoles quand je dis appartiennent à
ce secteur c'est vraiment des ouvriers
et des sourires à l'école dans la canne
à sucre qui est considérable c'est le
lamentin pour acheminer les lacs anne
lesur et ses terrasses et on a un réseau
ferré à l'époque de la menthe à ses 38
km de réseau ferré donc ça donne
vraiment ça vous donne vraiment les
éléments pour comprendre le poids que
joue le lamentable dans le secteur
agricole
le lamentin et un bastion communiste
depuis un peu plus d'une dizaine
d'années même plus une vingtaine
d'années depuis 1945 avec l'élection de
guillon donc on a en fait à la fois une
ville agricole où on a une majorité de
personnes qui sont des ouvriers et des
ouvrières et qui sont touchés par ce
message communiste puisqu'on à s'aimer
en communiste et on à la personne de
georges de rations qui a ce charisme et
ses talents d'orateur et puis cette
force de rassembler puis le parti
communiste a un rôle très éducatif sur
le lamentin on a des cellules qui
permette d'alphabétiser de connaître ses
droits
et c'est donc donc pour le coup les
événements se déclenche au lamentin mais
rapidement sa fm à la martinique
voilà et c'est pour ça que tout le monde
est touché à la martinique au soir du 24
mars quand on apprend qu'il y a eu cette
fusillade
donc une énième grève générale une
énième grève générale d'ailleurs pour la
petite histoire entre guillemets
la grève après le 24 et le 25 mars donc
l'entraînement de ces trois gènes
malheureusement on va avoir une
négociation qui vont redémarrer
puisqu'il ya les négociations
interrompues depuis le 9 mars
puisqu'en fait les patrons et la
préfecture on dit plutôt perdre la
récolte que de négocier une
revalorisation des salaires
c'était très clair donc ils redémarrent
les négociations on décide une faible
augmentation au lamentin il ya une telle
peur de représailles que finalement le
travail reprend de façon timide le
françois illy les autres les autres le
nord de la martinique reste très très
très très engagé dans cette grève
et finalement on va avoir début avril
une augmentation de 8% ce qui ne
représente pas vu l'inflation de
l'époque sont considérables ça ne
représente vraiment pas grand chose à
l'époque pour vivre un ouvrier ou une
ouvrière agricole dans la canne à sucre
à par jour l'équivalent de deux ans
voilà avec des familles extrêmement
nombreuses puisque nous sommes en pleine
explosion démographique
après la grève lors à noter un certain
nombre d'événements politiques
économiques mais là on a parlé
rapidement de la fin de la grève le
maire du lamentin qui prononce une
oraison funèbre le journal entièrement
après s'est passé à la postérité sous le
nom de discours des trois temps mais
c'est pas c'est pas un poème c'est un
discours jallet dit on pas politique
mais bon comme c'est un homme politique
un discours politique dé facto cela lui
sera reprochée puisqu'il est même fait
rarissime à l'époque est inimaginable
aujourd'hui poursuivis par le ministre
des armées et il est destitué de son
mandat de maire bon ben on a on a
vraiment eu l'honneur de pouvoir
rencontrer madame génération qui nous a
bien expliqué la chose tout à fait et
ella elle l'a été
comme on le voit dans le documentaire
touchés du fait que toute la population
ce soit même toute l'âme en scénic ce
soit quand même
alliés à un soutien à son mari pour
justement éviter qu'ils ne soient
qu'ils ne soient destitués quoi voilà il
a il a son mandat de bâtonnier a été
suspendu il ya eu toutes sortes toute
une série de mesures qui ont été prises
benoît rittaud roussillon après genre
gratien qui était l'un des dirigeants du
parti communiste camarade de route de
d'aimé césaire d'ailleurs jusqu'en 1957
et qui est devenu maire du lamentin
ensuite en 1959 jusqu'en 1989
d'ailleurs et qu'est ce que deviennent
les victimes survivantes anthony l'écran
d'un fruit puisque vous avez évoqué
cette question avec les témoins qu'elle
sont devenus des nombreux blessés les
personnes qui sans être blessés ont pu
un vécu ces événements puisque on disait
qu'il y avait entre 800 et 1000
personnes le monde au moment de la
fusillade de vendredi 24 mars
est ce qu on a une idée de de ce
qu'elles sont devenues l on continue de
vivre leur vie d'avant
on n'a qu'à changer de vie qui ont
déménagé est-ce que vous avez cette
perception
alors concrètement on ne sait pas bien
sûr devenu toutes ces personnes en tout
cas au niveau des interviews nous avons
quelques personnes qui sont décédées
aujourd'hui et
sinon le reste c'est vraiment pas et
pour les personnes qui ont vécu ça de
plus près celles qui ont été blessées ce
que vous avez eu l'occasion de
rencontrer des personnes qui les ont
côtoyés du tout en tout cas moi je n'ai
pas rencontré par me souvenir en tout
cas ce qu'on peut dire lors des d'autres
notre âne pour on a fait une projection
dans un des 40 chez du lamentin on a pu
rencontrer la soeur d'un des déchets
donc elle était assez contente de ce que
nous avions fait on a bien échangé la
bien échanger aussi avec vale huiyan
donc on est aussi content que quelle
qu'elle soit quand même satisfaite du
résultat est que voilà le le comment de
simples comme c'est un événement
sensible que ça puisse aller offerte un
deuil mais voit quand même que c'est pas
pris à la légère et que on ne fait pour
n'a pas fait du n'importe quoi non plus
avec eux puisque c'est la mémoire de
personnes qui ont existé il ya eu des
blessés et où on n'a quand même pas fait
du n'importe quoi avec cet événement là
donc ça aussi c'est important pour nous
les gendarmes et les policiers qui ont
participé à cet épisode le positifs
n'ont pas été poursuivis valériane elle
mérite alors de ce que de ce que j'ai pu
voir à l'heure actuelle en dix ans en
précisant bien quand même que l'histoire
prend du temps et que 60 ans ce n'est
rien
donc il ya des éléments que j'ai
aujourd'hui il ya des éléments qui vont
qui vont rester en suspens des questions
qui vont rester sans réponse pendant
encore un moment
en espérant que collègues en master
m'entendais choisissent te faire un
doctorat là dessus mais même ça ferait
avancer les choses plus vite c'est sûr
mais pour le coup il n'ya pas
apparemment de ce que j'ai pu voir à ce
stade il n'y a pas eu de poursuites il
n'y a pas eu d' enquête de manière
profonde ni fouillé il n'y a pas eu 10
gpn contacté pour pour essayer de faire
la lumière sur finalement qu'est ce qui
amène les forces de l'ordre à ouvrir le
feu en même temps dans les rapports les
choses sont très claires
ce sont hélas je cite des séparatistes
fin de citation
ce sont des des communistes et là je
cite encore des communistes sanguinaire
fin de fin de la citation donc il est
clair que les personnes qui grivet pour
les forces de l'ordre le 24 mars 61
étaient prêtes à attenter à leur vie
donc pour rétablir l'ordre et régler les
choses
ils ont ouvert le feu et donc ça ne pose
pas de questions ça ne semble pas
anormal et pour le coup après on allie
poursuite après georges gratiant alors
qu aucune enquête n'est fait concernant
l'assassinât de ces trois personnes
du reste la preuve d'achat ces dix ans
auparavant 1951 entre du coup c'est cet
esprit là je rêve du carembault en mars
1948 la grève de bassignac de 1923 après
les épisodes progressif le fait pour les
forces de l'ordre d'avoir tué ou blessé
des gens ça n'a jamais été l'objet d'une
enquête
de toute façon exactement c'est de toute
façon c'est la pratique de l'état à
cette époque ce qui pose question
finalement enfin je trouve que
finalement votre question à propos des
blessés qui aurait peut-être témoigner
je ne sais pas si des blessés dans ce
contexte la voudrait vraiment témoigner
en fait il même 60 ans après pour ceux
qui sont peut-être encore vivant s'il y
a vraiment cette volonté de livrer cette
part d'histoire alors que ce qui a été
dit d'un côté côté communiste c'est que
c'est des martyrs sur lesquels on a tiré
et cetera qui avaient des idéaux pour la
martinique
alors que pour certains c'était juste
être mieux payés et d'un autre côté on a
la version des forces de l'ordre garante
à cette époque de l'ordre néocolonial si
je peux dire les choses ainsi
qui estime qu on avait fait ça soit des
personnes sanguinaire et qu'il ne faut
pas laisser les communistes surtout
après la sphère des 16 de basse pointe
où on considère que c'est des
communistes qui ont assassiné
guy de fabrique c'est toute la
plaidoirie sont plus tôt voilà qui est
déroulé lors du procès en 51 à bordeaux
donc on ne va pas on ne va pas je ne
suis pas certaine que parler on se sent
on se sent tout à fait en sécurité on se
sent tout à fait à l'aise pour parler de
certaines choses
sans compter tout le processus
psychologique in iran un traumatisme
comme cela
face à la première
jean mas parti
voilà nous abordons le dernier la
dernière ligne droite de l'émission que
nous apprend le climat de 1961 60 ans
plus tard anthony lancry qu'est ce que
est ce qu'il ya un parallèle est ce
qu'il ya des similitudes que l'on peut
faire entre que la vie en martinique au
lamentin 1961 et celle d'aujourd'hui
pour ma part aussi il faut que je fasse
un parallèle on pourrait penser à 2009
on pourrait penser à cette année en
février je crois c'est ce sont ceux qui
me viennent à l'esprit tout de suite
puisque ce sont des mouvements qui ont
été très bons on craint pour doper la
martinique
et voilà d'accord est ce que donc il ya
de grandes différences également
évidemment la vie a complètement évolué
entre 60 ans est ce que ça vous a
surpris ce que vous avez découvert de la
lentille négligent à 60 ans par rapport
à ce que vous connaissez aujourd'hui a
pour moi c'est pas une découverte et je
pense que c'est plutôt une continuité et
je pense que c'est le même combat qui
est mené sous différentes formes et
non ça monsieur comprends et je pense
que c'est loin d'être terminé
laura l'unité même question est ce que
il y a des éléments de la vie
d'aujourd'hui que vous avez vu qui
existait déjà en 1960 oui il ya 60 ans
est un peu comme en fait ça permet en
tout cas moi ça m'a permis de mieux
comprendre peut-être certains événements
qui se passent actuellement certaines
peut-être revendications ou certains
points de vue notamment je pense au
secteur agricole qui bat 2,6 à la ça n'a
pas forcément changé et sont toujours
dans dans une demande de valorisation
voilà de revalorisation donc comme il
dit c'est vraiment c'est la continuité
sous une autre forme
après peut-être que ça implique un peu
plus la population
elle commence à prendre conscience la
population des des choses de ce qui se
fait mais pour moi l'important c'est de
connaître le son histoire pour pouvoir
mieux après appréhendés sont présents
voilà puisque peut-être qu'on le vit
mais en l'ayant nous vécu tuba dedans
lâchée en mai on vraiment profondément
en et en allant au coeur de l'histoire
même si ce n'est que sur le lamentin ça
nous a peut-être plus favorisés ou
sensibilisées à l'histoire sensibiliser
à la découverte de notre pays de notre
culture de notre patrimoine
et ça aussi c'est important qu'elles
consentent cette aventure cette histoire
ce film vous a appris à vous connecter à
mieux vous connecter à votre que votre
pays je rappelle que vous étiez au
collégial oui voilà c'est c'est à dire
que quand on est collégien on est un
adulte en devenir et c'est important
aussi de pouvoir se recentrer parfois
sur sur les choses de son pays puisque
c'est vrai que quand on est on est on
est on n'était pas encore super
connecter à l'époque encore plus
maintenant
et c'est vrai que malgré le fait qu'on
soit hyper connectés on n'a pas
forcément la fibre de l'histoire de
notre histoire
on va vouloir toujours s'intéresser à
l'histoire d'à côté mais c'est super
important est en fait c'est ce que je
retiens donc de toute l'expérience qu'on
a eu aussi aux vices comme chez soi au
ccj elle en étant conseil communal aussi
c'est à dire de vraiment s'imprégner de
se construire même si on va en extérieur
puisque on a d'autres jeunes du seuil du
service qui ont fait partie d'eux comme
chez soi qu'ils ont faits qui sont à
l'étranger ou en hexagone mais ils sont
plus cette fibre cette sensibilité au
patrimoine et à l'histoire mais qu'est
ce que vous avez retenu en tenue d'un
fruit de cette aventure comme je
reprends le mot de tout à l'heure de
tout ce que vous avez vécu il y a
maintenant quasiment en faisant douze
ans que lorsque vous avez réalisé le
film qu'est ce que vous avez retenu y
êtes pas retenir mais en tout cas
aujourd'hui grâce à sa jeunesse à
l'histoire de la martinique
et surtout je m'intéresse aux amis
grands parents parce que avant j'allais
bonjour mamie papy ça va mais quand il
ya des mouvements sociaux ou de grève
comme celle de 61 soit aujourd'hui mais
on en parle et je vois qu'il ya quand
même contraste parce que ma façon de
voir les choses et l'exprimé n'est pas
la même a vécu et même avec mes parents
c'est pareil quand même bien souvent
j'en parle avec mes parents et ensuite
je vois les grands-parents et on va
quand même bien une différence
puisqu'ils ont chacun leur époque et
plus on va et et plus et pire parce que
ils te disent qu'avant sa partie concert
avancer de telles façons ils caldwell
fait travail bit y'a bon je dis je parle
comme ça veut dire non mais c'est juste
peut-être que la forme n'est pas bonne
mais la cause et elle est bonne en fait
je vous disais tout à l'heure qu'il y
avait une permanence jusqu'en 1960 m m e
peu après
si on a parlé de ça pour la grève de
janvier février et d'inertie 74 dans la
manade pardon il y avait une permanence
des structures sociales économiques de
la société d'habitation est ce qu'on
peut dire aujourd'hui cela a disparu où
il y a encore des survivants
moi je crois qu'il y à beaucoup de
choses qui ont disparu je pense que je
pense que la différence entre en 61 les
gens n'avaient pas de voiture en
martinique
aujourd'hui on croule sous les
embouteillages littéralement le fait de
pouvoir s'acheter une voiture
je mesure ce que je dis mais vraiment le
fait de pouvoir travailler et s'acheter
sa voiture c'est des choses qui ont
évolué avant ce n'était pas possible non
seulement parce qu'on n'en avait pas les
moyens mais aussi parce qu on
appartenait à une catégorie socio
raciale maintenant il y a des relents de
cette société et ses relents s'exprime
par exemple directement quand on va dire
charbon chabine mais là tu remues
l'atrice et qu'on va continuer à
fonctionner même si on est tous mélangés
au carnaval
mais bon il ya des endroits où c'est
plutôt les mulâtres il ya des endroits
où c'est les bégué on a des espaces et
des gay comme ça et en fait on n'en
parle jamais des espaces exigus
oui masse comme ça que je vois les
choses et c'est comme ça que je les
appelle c'est des espaces où en fait on
sait que ça va être telle catégorie
socio raciale qui pourra y être parce
que dans notre histoire races et classes
sociales sont complètement imbriqués et
donc on va avoir ses espaces où
finalement on ne va pas formulé on va
pas le dis on va le penser mais c'est
évident puisque tout le monde n'y va pas
voilà c'est le même principe qu'on a
aujourd'hui
et ça pour le coup ça n'a pas changé
donc on a à la fois des améliorations
nettes qui ne qui ne posent pas question
et on n'est pas du tout il ya 60 ans
clairement il pouvait dire nous sommes
encore dans une société esclavagiste
aujourd'hui en 2021 on ne peut pas
affirmer ça ce n'est pas possible
maintenant on a des relents on a des
mécanismes de domination qui perdurent
des stigmates et c'est à nous de nous
interroger à la fois personnellement à
la fois collectivement mais aussi
en faisant confiance à nos chercheurs en
faisant confiance aussi à nos jeunes qui
peuvent mener des projets culturels qui
servent justement à s'interroger à
déconstruire ces choses là et pour moi
c'est très important
voilà alors à l'honnêteté pour la fin de
l'émission qu'est-ce que vous devenez
aujourd'hui vous n'avez pas fait qu'un
film documentaire quand vous étiez au
collège qu'est ce que vous faites
aujourd'hui
alors aujourd'hui ben on est enfin en
tout cas je suis services comme chez soi
de l'office de la culture donc comme il
a été précisé au début nous étions
jeunes
on venait le mercredi et le samedi et on
est en fait comme on est tombé dans la
marmite donc on y est toujours au niveau
de l'animation et donc on participe dès
que possible et oui pas principalement
aux à tout ce qui est un événement
culturel office de la culture du
lamentin et aussi avec la ville du
lamentin et bien si ça reste une tête
très bonne expérience
voilà quant à lui n'a pris donc vous
encadrez à votre taux des jeunes oui
c'est ça donc on reste toujours dans la
continuité dans la transmission que moi
aujourd'hui j'ai travers l'office de
l'inventaire au service comme chez soi
en tant qu'assistant projectionniste
donc dans l'éducation à l'image dans les
quartiers au lamentin je ne vais pas
dire qu'est ce que vous devenez la
médiation
on dirait de la mission je vous ai
présenté comme préparer une thèse en
histoire de mots rapidement pour c'est
vrai que ça n'a rien à voir avec la
grève de mars il ya 60 ans mais sur la
thèse ma grande passion
non le principe de cette thèse pour le
coup c'est une question que je me pose
c'est comment on parle de la mémoire de
l esclavage nos musiques en guadeloupe
et en martinique et on a tendance à
penser qu'on ne peut finalement on
parlait pas du tout du tout d'esclaves
âge mais j'espère en tout cas le corpus
de chansons que je suis en train de
constituer est en train de démontrer que
non voilà nous y sommes encore donc
merci laura l'honnêté anthony lancry
collaborateurs du l'office de la culture
du lamentin et valériane edmond-mariette
chercheuse en histoire c'est ainsi que
se compliquer
conclut notre émission face à la
première réalisée par jean louis borg
edit le curieux que vous pourrez
retrouver sur notre site internet par
tite et que la première à partir de
demain lundi dans quelques instants les
dernières informations avec le journal
de la rédaction de martinique la
première je vous retrouve dimanche
prochain pour une nouvelle émission et
puis pour vous saluer avant de prendre
notre poche cette citation de calmants
que ça va bien avec l'émission une
phrase tirée de son manifeste du parti
communiste écrit avec son ami frais des
canisses en 1848 celui qui ne connaît
pas l'histoire est condamné à la revivre
à bientôt face à la première
[Musique]
oh